[Applause]
[Applause]
seriously TomSka doesn't have a gag
reflex has no name for herself our
entire family and Joe thinks he wet
himself on all long plates that he
sleeps on
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
everybody give her a big happy birthday
[Applause]
[Applause]
I know why isn't there blood right now
Oh oh thank god nothing guys thank you
for having me
[Applause]
what
are you having fun at our little gets
you party yeah absolutely
[Music]
that this person was alive
instead helping it so much he actually
needs to feel comfortable so the first
major so he's adjusted
[Music]
it really makes you it's like hey you
wanna
[Music]
like everyone's record again he's in a
box
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
guys I'm so excited every time I have
been in New York I've been trying to go
to the bnh location here I'm here with
Joey
we're so close we're so close I can't
believe it I'm gonna buy I'm gonna buy a
camera charger and I don't know what
else I'm gonna get and you need a camera
it's real both sighing oh it is Daniel
you better not give up anybody didn't
like what this is a great day I'm really
glad that I'm here sharing it with some
fellow creators we can really enjoy it
shots YUM Oh like Candyland this is not
even I'm so excited oh my goodness
my arm sale today my goodness like
people might think ah they packed
everything here Wow
they call the dead kitten or something
they're called dead yes they are or
something like that
it is where's the canon section we just
had a really excellent experience and
Joey is now unboxing because g7x here
it's really sad and as we were filming
the David Blaine a little segment
because like this camera died it's okay
I'll give you the clip I have I have the
clip of Joey listening to me oh my god
it looks so fresh mine my feet smell it
was a smelly good no it smells like a
camera girl
Lisa Frank stickers did you see saws the
iPhone 4 cute
and it's actually the five it looks like
it has the fingerprint sensor so with
the sticker does it work
no no stickers represent my soul
[Music]